c'était le grand retour du Paris
Versailles trois ans après 25000
coureurs ont répondu présent ce dimanche
25 septembre pour cette épreuve
historique de 16 km entre la Tour Eiffel
et l'avenue de Paris à Versailles ça
fait beaucoup de bien de voir ça et en
plus il fait beau on a connu des Paris
Versailles plus vieux et là ça fait
plaisir tout est conditions étaient
réunies et on est content de revoir
cette très belle course chez les hommes
Justin dourlant de l'Union athlétique de
Versailles termine premier au bout de
l'effort avec un chrono de 53 minutes et
une seconde à versailler vainqueur dans
la cité royale une grande première dans
l'histoire de cette grande classique
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est pas de
faire un chrono mais vraiment d'aller
chercher la victoire et dernier 300
mètres bon voilà j'ai fait une grosse
accélération pour aller chercher la
gagne quoi je m'attendais pas du tout à
gagner en 2019 j'ai fait 13e et là cette
année je vais aller en top 5
est les premiers après 16 km de course
sont en 58 minutes et 57 secondes
surtout que je suis pas très bonne en
côte donc après on est un peu mais
franchement je suis super contente la
course créée en 1976 reviendra pour une
44e édition l'année prochaine et espère
toujours attirer 25000 couronnes